mid-range shooting team  in these playoffs it's booker over two  got it fouled  you remember that iconic pose that we  saw from devin booker in the bubble when  he was hitting game winners laying on  the floor  from the identical spot devin booker  fills the contact  six to play  booker this is for the win got it  wow  [Applause]  what  a shot  by devin booker  right there  [Applause]  unbelievable play  but again  [Music]  that is good for sure  what a shot  devin booker today  what's the sons now  three and oh in the bubble they need  help to make the playoffs for that  play-in game  they confirm  they are learning a lot in a short while  here look at the defense paul george let  me tell you something  there's no way that paul george could  have played any better defense